the directive for automatic exchange of
advance tax rulings has received a lot
of attention because its goal is to
combat aggressive tax planning and to
make sure that the companies pay their
fair share of taxes we are going to have
a retroactivity period of five years in
this directive going back to 2012 by
agreeing today on this directive the EU
is showing the way you had companies
larger ones normally that paid very
little or no taxes at all so we want to
reform that when I say we arm in the
European Union but I also mean the g20
this is a very complete exercise of
modernizing taxation worldwide and the
decision that we've taken here today is
an element of the whole puzzle where we
make sure that we fight for transparency
at EU level so that we will not have the
end result that we used to have that
certain corporations could in all
legality avoid taxation produce it them
or a number of member states I'm Alex
and presence a aspects mission to start
to work on the impact thing in budget
and economic terms for EU countries on
the refugee crisis it's too early for me
to say today whether certain specific
derogations for seen under the pack in
particularly occurrence of exceptional
circumstances can be taken into account
in any future evaluation so that's what
I could say on that subject well as it
savvy pact which will be respected you
saw LOL